we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 David P here is a really good
question about the right and the
pandemic beautifully asked take a listen
to this
yeah hey David this is a Troy column
from uh Georgia yeah I just had a
question for you that I don't think I've
ever seen anybody ask
you know people that are against vaccine
and mask mandates yeah
um
I've always wanted somebody to ask the
opposing side well what is it that you
want our government to do right to fight
this pandemic nothing because I haven't
heard any other suggestions of what we
could do other than mask up and try to
get everybody vaccinated yep do they
want to just let
this thing run rampant yeah here's the
this is a great question right so you're
against the government saying what
should happen in schools let schools and
parents figure it out
you're against government saying you got
to wear masks you're against government
saying you got to get vaccinated to work
here to work there to go here there to
travel in this particular way you're
against businesses having capacity
limits they want to leave it to the
business to decide leave it to the
people to say oh I I want to go to this
business or I don't I'll everybody will
just kind of make their own decisions
this is the point they they don't want
anything to be done many of them never
believed it was serious enough to have
anything done involving the government
many of them believe that anything
government does is overreach and yet now
they're okay with government passing a
ban on mass mandates and so it's
completely hypocritical but you have to
understand their framing is it should be
Freedom leave it to people and
businesses to figure out
except once a business says well you've
got to wear a mask to come in or you've
got to be vaccinated to come in then
they want to pass laws that say no no
you can't do that ban mask mandates ban
vaccine requirements to do business so
it's the wrong approach this this is
sort of like
when we say
aren't Republicans going to be punished
for obstructing everything Democrats
want to do no no no the obstruction is a
feature if your world view is I don't
want government doing anything or I want
government doing as little as possible
you see obstruction by government
officials
as a feature rather than a bug they are
doing the thing you want them to do they
are preventing government from doing
stuff and so of course it makes
absolutely no sense whatsoever
extraordinarily dangerous and we see how
it's worked out for the United States
and particularly when you look at the
red States now or the red counties now
case rates growing at twice the rate in
red counties as in blue counties it has
failed completely it's a perfect
question if not masks if not vaccines if
not how do they think government should
be involved in fighting this pandemic
many of them believe government should
not be involved and that's a horrifying
thing and most of them would concede
even small government conservatives
would tend to concede government should
keep us safe from threats the threat
doesn't have to be a military threat
from another country
it doesn't have to be a cyber threat
from another country or Bad actors it
can be a medical threat a public health
threat and that's exactly what it is so
that it's uh you have to really get into
their mindset to understand they want
the government doing nothing they don't
think the government should be involved
we have a great bonus show for you today
we're going to talk about what's in the
infrastructure Bill what's actually in
the bill that is going to be debated in
the Senate we will talk about how a
million Texans have registered to vote
online since a Court ruling said you can
register to vote online we will also
talk about new McDonald's policy every
employee must wear a mask every customer
must wear a mask there are McDonald's
addicts who also hate masks who are
going crazy what will they do will they
go to Burger King will they go to
Wendy's will they maybe make a salad we
will talk about all of those stories and
more on today's bonus show get instant
access by signing up right now I mean
it's truly instant the speed of light at
joinpakman.com